-Hi, Ces!
-Hi. Hi, Seth!
-It's so nice to see you.
And I want to start
by congratulating you
on your Emmy nomination
this year.
So well-deserved.
-Well, thank you. It was -
And I've never been
so happy to lose, I think.
-Because you're a fan
of who won in your category.
-Yes. I mean,
I'm a fan of everybody.
But I was like --
I joke that I was maybe
only third on my own list.
-This is --
We should give a shout-out
This is Annie Murphy
of "Schitt's Creek"
that won in your category,
and that is a show you love.
-Yes. Has it been announced?
-I think it's out now.
It's a little weird.
The end schedule
is weird this year.
-Yeah.
-This is very exciting for u
to see you because you wer
one of the last people we ha
in studio before everythin
went sideways back in March.
-Oh, I know.
And I was talking so big.
And I said I was going to go
to the soccer game, which I did.
I went to an arena on Sunday
And the person I was with
was sick by Thursday.
-Really?
That was the Thursday
where everybody
basically left town, right
-Yeah. Well, I quarantined
for two weeks.
-You lived your best life
right up until the last minute
-[ Laughs ] I sure did.
I got to see
the soccer team win.
The U.S. Women's National team
-You had something that is
I think, on par
with that kind victory.
Which is -- A lot of times
people will now --
Because they know your skill
as an impressionist,
they will cast you
from the public,
and someone suggested you play
Don Junior's girlfriend,
Kimberly Guilfoyle,
and it was Bette Midler
in a tweet.
-It was the divine Miss Midler
I cannot believe it.
I e-mailed Lorne immediately
after I saw that tweet.
-And he responded.
-I was like, "Bette Midler
said to do it, so..."
And he said...
[As Lorne] "We'll get the wig.
-That's so nice of him.
He has such good wig contacts.
-Yeah. Yeah. He got his --
He's giving me one of his.
-Oh. That's nice.
You -- My personal favorite --
And I think I text you
almost every time
you do Jeanine Pirro.
Is this as much fun to do
as it is to watch?
-Yes. Absolutely.
And it's fun because Colin i
always a little bit surprised,
and he enjoys it so much,
being tortured.
-Yeah, I feel like
that kind of woman
throwing a drink on Collin
is like a weird, like,
maybe fantasy of his.
-[ Laughs ] Probably.
But I don't want
to think about it that way
because it'll
change things for me.
-It'll put you in your hea
the next time you do it.
-Yeah.
It's kind of fun,
you know, playing her.
And then even with
Bette Midler tweeting,
I've never felt more honored
than, like,
when a crazed brunette screams
on television,
people think of me.
-Yeah. That's true.
If saw a crazy brunette,
I'd think, "Uh-oh.
You're about to get Cecily'd."
-"That's Cecily." Yeah.
-I think one of
the exciting things
about Saturday that everybody'
looking forward to
is Jim Carrey's gonna be there
He's gonna be playing Joe Biden.
And the last time he hosted,
there was
the Carrey Family Reunion.
And there you are
as Fire Marshall Bill.
A very convincing
Fire Marshall Bill.
-Classic look. Yes.
-Was that good times?
-That was so cool, because
it was one of the instance
that happens a lot on our show
where you get to meet,
like, your comedy heroes,
and it was nice --
Doing a sketch like that,
we kind of got to show him
And I think he really
appreciated it, too.
-Not all --
This is a little heartbreaking
but I think it's good
for young actors out there
to know that not --
you don't succeed at every turn.
Not all of your impression
have made it on "SNL."
You have an impression
of Idris Elba
on the television show "Luther."
-Yeah. It has to be "Luther.
-Right.
This is not
an Idris Elba impression.
This is specific
to the BBC cop show "Luther.
-And I wound up doing it for him
at the host dinner.
-And did he like it?
-He said he did.
And I'll tell you what he said
after I do it.
Because it's mainly --
it's a physical thing.
-Okay.
-He just goes...
[as John Luther] "No.
You won't, though, will ya
'Cause I'm a coppa!
And it's Ian, mate!"
[Normal voice]
It's a lot of just --
And he went -- [As Elba]
"So a lot of squintin'?"
And that's a bad Idris.
That's --
I was playing him then,
not Luther.
And I said,
"Yeah, well, you're tired.
Luther's tired."
-Luther's tired.
He's a little over it.
I think his job is obviously
made a lot harder.
-His job is freaking exhausting!
-It's exhausting.
But I think I missed that,
that Luther is often
sort of just working --
A lot of this, yeah.
A lot of working the chin
for old Luther.
-Yeah.
-And then I believe you were
just listing
the other characters
that work with Luther.
Those were just his colleagues
-Yeah, that's a lot of
my impression work,
is just me saying the othe
names of people on the show.
-Well, it makes it
very clear to the person
you're doing the impression of
that you've seen the work.
-Yes. Brett Butler --
I just yell at Quentin
when I do "Grace Under Fire.
-Well, I think you can't d
a Luther and not do Brett butler
from "Grace Under Fire."
-Well, it's just like,
[As Grace Kelly]
"Quentin, Quentin.
Go get Russell
at the pharmacy, Quentin.
Where is Nadine?"
[Normal voice]
So, again, it's a lot of
the other characters.
-Do you get asked
to do that one a lot?
-Um, I did it once, and then
they stopped asking me...
-Well, that's --
-...if there's an impression
I'm hiding.
You know how they do that
on the show?
-Oh, right, right, right.
-They e-mail you once a week
-Oh. Oh, I see.
Like, yeah, right.
They want to do
an impression parade sketch,
and they'll say,
"Hey, do you have anything
in your back pocket?"
And that's what you drop them.
And I'm like,
"Well, 'Grace Under Fire.'
-This is very --
There was very exciting news
that was released today.
You have a show that's
coming out on "Apple TV."
-Yes.
-Where are you in
the production schedule of that?
Just about to start?
Is that accurate-ish?
-Ish, yes. I'm not 100%.
I don't know about anything.
I'm locked in a house.
-But it's an incredible cast
-I'm so excited about this cast.
We got --
I mean, I've been, like,
waiting to scream it
from the mountaintops.
Just to get to work with -
Keegan is my co-star.
And then all these
amazing Broadway folks.
And it's just -- I'm thrilled.
I've only had a Zoom
cocktail party with them so far.
-is the title official? Is i
officially the title I've heard?
-No.
-Great.
Then I won't say it.
-Yeah.
Well you can say whatever
you want, and you'll be wrong.
-Well, I try to avoid that
at all costs.
-Unless, I mean, if you have
a good idea. By all means.
-But this is you
and Keegan Michael Key.
You're basically a couple
that stumbles onto
sort of a magical land
where everybody believes
they're in a musical.
-Yes. Fred is in it.
-Fred. Kristin Chenoweth.
-We're getting Fred.
-Kristin Chenoweth.
Alan Cumming. Aaron Tveit.
Dove Cameron. Ariana DeBose.
It's really exciting.
-That's amazing.
Congrats on that Cecily.
I can't wait for Saturday. It'
always such a joy to see you
Thanks for being here.
-Yeah. Thank you, Seth.
-I'll see you soon.